in the previous lectures
we talked about predictive modeling
pipeline
it involved multiple computational steps
in this lecture we'll focus on
performance evaluation and what are
those different performance evaluation
metrics
predictive model is a function that map
feature x to predict
output target y the most common
predictive models are either
classification problems or regression
problem
for classifications the target variable
y is either binary or categorical
there are many performance metrics
associated with classification problems
such as true positive rate false
positive rate
positive predictive values f1 score area
under the roc curve and many
many more on the other hand if the
target variable y is continuous
we also have a different performance
metrics
such as mean absolute error mean squared
error and are squared
in this lecture we'll go through all
those different performance metrics and
explain the definitions
and how they're related to each other